hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another impossible Let's
Plays this time featuring the leg waxing
challenge you can't quite see but I've
got a leg waxing kit just off the screen
here and I'm gonna be playing the
impossible quiz book chapter 3 and
here's how it's gonna work every time I
lose all 5 lives or I get a game over in
any regard I have to wax one strip off
of my leg here and I keep going until
it's just too much to tolerate but
people do this all the time men and
women everyday they wax all the time it
can't be that bad maybe no time to waste
let's get into it
what does B C stand for before Chris
bumhole cheese Barry chuckle or whatever
all that is oh god a bird arm turtle
shell in his house vulture and an
eyeball oh no what does any of that mean
[Music]
Oh what do i do what do i do I don't
know this why should I know this why do
I know that okay why okay when was the
earth formed five billion years ago 69
BC around lunchtime dinasaur in a top oh
my god I'm so gonna die what does the
Ice Age I don't know
no because it's stoic there oh okay well
this happened much sooner than I thought
it was gonna no time to waste I don't
know if you guys can see in that camera
but I got my wax sitting in a double
water here I think I may need to heat
this up some more be right back
everybody
okay Sun back now some slightly warmer
and more malleable wax let's get to it
it said you were supposed to supply it
in the direction of the hair growth
which is what I'm doing
oh that feels good ah I don't know how
long you're supposed to wait
is it kind of deal where the longer you
wait the longer the worse it gets kind
of deal or do I have to go now is it not
gonna work no no guys oh how is this so
bad
look at that I got a nice clean leg that
works out pretty nicely
that wasn't bad at all alright maybe I
can actually do this I was very prepared
for that to be horrible one more go
dinasaur in a top hat now oh god that
was real right to 20,000 oh god 10,000
what do you mean oh the movie how many
holes in a troll ole-ole I don't know
how am I supposed to know this how do
you expect me to know this 5-1 right no
three an absolute stupid huh again
already
why okay here we go again it wasn't that
bad man anybody who complains about
waxing their leg must be a giant baby oh
that's good right there
that's good ow ow ow okay alright let's
see I'll show you this one guys to City
you know I ain't fitten I'm really
kidding it sleazy pretty nice big piece
great Duke oh it is so smooth thanks
really ill oh did you see that oh that's
so nice three not three four four how do
you make a dinosaur get on the floor
open the door get on the floor everybody
do the dinosaur bat oh I get up the arse
oh god what here is it Chinese dragon
2006 please I guess there's a reason why
they call the impossible game
there we go oh my leg I'm gonna get my
whole leg done oh really layer it on
there get it nice and get that down
it doesn't feel pretty good in a way I
wouldn't mind doing this all the time 3
2 1 oh oh that's nice that's nice right
there
God my leg is so smooth that is weird
Kate up the arse to that for why 2004 oh
god what am i doing oh no no no no no no
no no no no no no no is it by black
darkness yeah you are Kate oh god I
don't know what do you want from me
what do you want to me game what do you
want for me my hands sticky I can't
click oh god no no no no critic read the
universe lady vain Oh probably big bang
or something like that okay
more waxing I don't know why I'm
choosing to pursue pain bow pretty one
wow it doesn't feel good
my hands are all sticky I'm gonna make
my mouse sticky
what is TARDIS stand for these ankles
really don't impress seagulls or how
about bees ankles bangles tea and
related drinks in Scunthorpe sitting are
striated nicking impossible [ __ ] quiz
that sounds right to me
oh no skip skip
give me the skip no God
how's I supposed to know you're gonna
give me a choice alright more to go
let me try might we try my like upper
leg bear with me a little bit oh okay
that already feels good I'll get a nice
big one on the upper thigh
don't imagine this would feel good and
again I didn't imagine it all would feel
good three two one Oh bad Oh Brill's can
I wax my hands are so disgusting I'm
sweating already
bang girl was it pac-man what about as
well as oh I don't know what you want
from it all God which is the sexiest
guitar string G is it G hey find the
treasure God with these bombs dig marf
dog treasure
oh I know where it is Oh oh my god what
are you going Nazi hairdresser I knew
Ska's sixth hair hair snip hair snip
hair snip snip these bombs what am I
supposed to Oh God
Oh what did I do wrong
suck guy are you seeing this just
testing oh my god goodbye armpit hair
that I've had since puberty time to give
you the love and attention you deserve
and by that I mean I'm gonna rip you out
and then throw you away Yolo baby three
do it 100
[Music]
Oh Oh see oh my god oh that's a
nightmare that's the first one that
actually legitimately hurt am i
beautiful yet do you find me sexy Oh
everywhere shower what else can I ask me
my Tumtum I got some air on my tummy
I'll be do that let me do it one more
time
hair snip and then don't pet the kitty
what if I school no all right fine
all right some time time come here good
boy sorry I didn't mean to screw you did
my bug this is gonna feel good right
over the belly button right over my scar
wow it hurts already I think I didn't
put the ah frizzling all over bike ride
hey one more go I don't even know you
guys can see you don't stand up a bit I
want to give you guys good show three
they didn't even do that much that's
read already the best this is still sick
best feels are dirty I wish I could wax
more I'm not waxing my head anyone
thinking that right now anyone writing
in that in the comments or if you have
already how dare you how dare you very
much so so it's like at the end of these
I get the sudden realization why why do
I do this so that'll be the end of the
leg waxing challenge which turned into
the whole body waxing challenge so I
hope you guys enjoyed that so thank you
all so much for watching we will like if
you enjoyed this for my suffering and if
you have a suggested for the next
impossible that's why you want to see me
do let me know in the comments below
thanks again everybody um I really got
the bells as a thanks again for watching
really I honestly appreciate I'm so and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]